I want to start by saying I saw the
movie yesterday and Wow I had heard it
was good and it was yeah one of the
things about it though is it's like
every 20 minutes I'm constantly saying
WTF like it's constantly making you
wonder what the hell is going on yeah so
I'm curious for both of you
how were you sort of when you told the
story and like or how much was it like
your people telling you just read the
script and you being like what the [ __ ]
is going on yeah I mean would you like
to I for me I had the audition so I had
the script along with the audition and
as soon as I opened it and started
reading I was immediately immersed into
what it could possibly look like and it
was a complete page-turner I mean the
movie is beautiful in its own but so is
the script I think the script is written
so wonderfully and I just I couldn't put
it down and I loved watching the
character development it seemed like
these two girls on these rollercoaster
rides that are like intertwining but
going other ways and then you find out
that the whole thing connects at the
very beginning but you didn't see it
like it's honestly it was a fantastic
experience reading it so performing it
was you know exponentially that much
better yeah I think my experience was a
text from Richard Shepherd who I had
worked with on girls for six years who
says I'm having a script delivered to
like the hard copy I was like what is
this old Hollywood this is very exciting
and is that I'm having a script
delivered to you it's insane call me as
soon as you finish it I was like oh if
you think it's insane and you think I'm
gonna think it's insane it was gonna be
insane and sure enough it was I couldn't
put it down I just read it in one
sitting I was wrong about every
prediction I made in the margins with my
pen about where I thought it was gonna
go which I thought was a great sign then
I called him afterwards and I was like
let's do it I've got to do it I've got
to figure out who Charlotte is I've got
to play her I've got to be part of this
I was gonna say good I was watching it
because we've all seen a million movies
and it's like you constantly think you
know where it's gonna go and in the
first 30 minutes I was dead wrong oh
yeah oh yeah I mean everything I thought
was completely wrong good yeah it's
humbling right I mean I'd the whole time
in the script I was like I know this
genre I'm pretty good at this now I'm
hip to these little plot twists and I
was like oh my god I've never
so wrong and then I kept being wrong and
then I just
yeah there's stuff you miss and then the
second time you see it it just seems
like how could I not have seen where
this was going but I I that is so much
fun for me and especially when you're
dealing with subject areas that people
struggle to figure out how to talk about
in a non literal way by putting it in
this genre you get to completely spin it
on its head and just have a totally
different kind of conversation in a
different context about this stuff and
I'm being very vague on purpose but
hopefully we'll people have seen it and
then watch this entry though it will
make sense
yes there's so much I would love to dive
into which I cannot do it again so chill
we're gonna stay here we're gonna stay
right here and then you're come back and
we'll talk about it exactly uh so I
would imagine making this must have been
crazy and fun and what's like a day or
two that you will always remember the
bus Shanghai I would say I remember
except we were so jet-lagged the whole
time we were there that it was like it
felt like a dream at the time the bus
was hardcore the bus was hard because we
had a skeleton crew we had the other
actors on the bus it's not literal
skeletons just doing a game of Thrones
robbing those they were regular
flesh-and-blood human beings really but
there was a smaller an actual bus you
know we're yeah it's actually bumping
around and I remember one of the hardest
things we did was um I don't know if it
was that we took a break in the day or
came back on another day but just having
to stop everything that momentum that we
were building I think it's probably
lunch and then coming back and it's like
here and we're just throwing back into
the part where you're it's just free man
yeah that's the bus was very very
intense um oh it's a member Richard
Richard had like a little so he couldn't
be seen you know we're filming the whole
bus so you know I've been doing it we
say that I don't know people be able to
their Easter I think we talk about those
little Easter eggs later yeah I think
we're gonna talk about that later
because there are some very funny ways
that we were able to achieve the bus and
there's another another way that I think
it's very funny as well but I don't
think we should say I understand I don't
wanna get you guys in trouble yeah
exactly
there's a lot of spoilers you could
discuss in this thing and really break
it down and I wish I've said it now
twice again well I don't want them to
cut me from the film yeah we'll just be
here that would be impossible
that would look even more insane just
like yeah boy one of the things though
the movies about an hour and a half in
it flies and it doesn't feel like
there's any waste of time okay but talk
a little bit were there deleted scenes
was there stuff that you remember that
didn't make the final cut there are a
few little moments but nothing major
[Music]
like just a mouth whisper it's me yes
but it was stuff that ended up being
yeah unnecessary and in the name of
keeping it feeling like you're on a
moving bus like the movie is just
happening whether you like it or not and
it's speeding along and you kind of
don't have time to assess it anything
that disrupted that momentum either had
to be completely deliberate and like we
wanted everything to come to a
screeching halt for a second or had to
go because it just is about momentum and
I think I think Richard did a beautiful
job of figuring out where to cut the fat
and there were scenes added that we
realized after he cut the whole thing he
realized you know there are parts of the
the chain that are missing to make this
a whole film for the characters and so
we went back and added some things which
I'm so glad we did because I think it
really rounds out the story that we're
telling and you'll never know what they
were my last thing for you
do you remember there's a completely
different question do you remember your
first movie or TV show crush Han Solo
not even like I don't know I don't even
know what that was very fast it's so in
my bones and it's so on the surface
still to this day but the love at well I
in non-animated I guess staphon in
Terkel in Family Matters I guess I can't
really remember but like I remember but
then kind of Steve because I'm like wait
Steve is turning into Stephon
that's Palazzo s and that's when I
probably started liking like engineers
it was like my for my boyfriend sounds
like ooh are you gonna turn into
something else or highlights of
impossible old aircraft do you is there
a TV show that you'd love to guest star
on oh okay my Thrones would have been so
fun oh yeah I just want to be on a horse
and so we just put me on a horse I'm
just dying to be on a horse and of
course it and it just seems like the
Brits just won't accept me and I get it
a very American vibe but I would do
anything just olden times fireplace
horse corset I do like that world I
don't know if you've read children of
blood and bone yet but like that it's
basically like the African female
version of Harry Potter so like in
anything like that would be dope yeah I
was gonna say I haven't read it yet but
I really mean it congratulations on this
movie
it was so well done you guys have a
fantastic day good luck with the rest of
the presentation